come to my house take over my room they
tell me let me take over it other way
people is it true you gave me a book to
that's right okay thank you for the book
I took it back I started reading it I
made notes and then I stupidly forgot to
bring it no problem the book so I would
like no I don't to bring us me happy
yeah the book on a and material I'm
happy to discuss that in future day now
you raised the issue of the badges I've
just done a long chat with J we got on
if you're just going to call me a
hypocrite for you know think about us
especially especially our respect
especially algerians all the Muslims
love but when it comes to Algerian this
very very sensitive to me there's no two
states Dro I
know this is this is I understand this
it's contradiction it's contradiction
the point here is Philistine there's
only one country the Jewish people are
welcome to live there but you cannot
take over a country then tell them if
you don't allow me to to live or take
over you you terrorist yes I don't
accept that you are you are contradict
you are more confused than confused.com
may Allah guide you take running away
I'm going to PR